The mid-1800s gave us Bray Rands, those delusional mystics who swore they could live on sunlight alone.
Hira Rattan Manik, for instance, claimed to have survived for years by eating the sun,
as if the universe owed him a metabolic miracle.
Science, of course, laughed him out of the room.
But what if the real lesson wasn't that they could defy biology?
What if it was that they'd found a way to make biology irrelevant?
Because here's the thing. Misery doesn't need survival. It needs distraction.
And so we turn to what we call Asterisk the Desert Strategy.
Water is the enemy. Not because it's evil. No, it's far worse than that.
It's efficient. It cools you down when you're hot. It sharpens your mind when you're foggy.
It washes away the toxins that make you feel like you've been run over by a truck.
But we can't have that. Not when clarity is the first step toward fixing anything.
So instead, we let ourselves dry up.
Just a 1% loss of hydration, and suddenly your thoughts turn sluggish.
Your mood swings like a door in the wind.
Your focus? Gone.
Poof.
Vanished like a mirage.
And that, my friend, is the point.
When you're hydrated, you're capable.
You can solve problems.
You can see solutions.
You can even, God forbid, imagine a life that isn't this one.
So we do the opposite.
We starve ourselves of the one thing that keeps us from drowning in our own stagnation.
The process begins with the caffeine filter.
No more water.
Just black coffee.
Energy drinks.
Anything that promises a jolt while secretly leeching what little moisture you have left.
Every sip is a betrayal.
Your body takes it, processes it, and then all.
Then it expels it.
A diuretic's cruel joke.
You drink to stay alive.
And in return, you lose more of what keeps you alive.
Then comes the sodium barrier.
Salt.
The silent saboteur.
It doesn't just make you thirsty.
It steals from your cells, turning your flesh into a biological wasteland.